octopus are hackers who cracked cyber
security service providers using the
most banal of methods sounds crazy
doesn't it the organization got its name
in 2022 when it stole the data and
two-factor authentication codes of OCTA
customers an American identity and
access management company as a result
more than 130 companies were affected
and the number of compromised accounts
reached almost 10 000 among these
companies were twilio MailChimp and
clavio as well as the messaging app
signal in their telegram channel the
attackers stated that they were
interested in Octa customers and not the
company itself but how did they pull
this off with the help of social
engineering octopus simply sent messages
to employees with links to phishing
sites people entered their data thinking
they were logging in but in fact they
simply gave hackers access to their
accounts even though everyone in the
world warned you against clicking on
questionable links people still fall for
this trap stay safe by subscribing to
our Channel